Okay, Michael.
So, let me sort of jump in on that
last thing that you asked me.
We've just been talking about
how to compute probabilities
of optimal actions based upon
what human beings are giving us.
And that's fine.
But it turns out we actually have
multiple sources of information, and
we would like to be
able to combine them.
In particular,
we have some policy that we've learned
that gives us a probability distribution
over actions that we learn from a human,
that's why it says pi sub H here.
And you notice here I'm treating
a policy as a probability distribution
over actions, and that's all neat.
And these, in fact, are the numbers
that we came up with in our last quiz.
But while the agent is
running around in the world.
The agent has information from
running around in the world, right?
There were rewards.
I've actually gone through and
played Pac-Man.
And I've been eaten and I've won and
I've gone through rooms and
I've done all these kinds of things.
And it seems kind of silly to ignore
what I actually know about what's going
on in the world, particularly in the
case where human being might, in fact,
be incorrect sometimes,
or may really believe that
the optimal policy is one thing,
but in fact, for the underlying NVP,
the optimal policy is something else.
So, I just want to ask you a couple
of really simple questions.
Let's imagine that I've got some
algorithm that runs around in the world,
on its own, and learns distributions
over actions in every given state, okay?
And it says after a little while that
the probability that action x is optimal
as 1/3, action y is optimal as 1/3, and
action z is being optimal is also 1/3.
And so now I've got two
sources of information here,
what the humans told me, and I know
that's 2/3, 1/6, 1/6 because math, and
I've learned from experience so
far that all actions are equally likely.
>> Which is pretty non-committal.
>> It is pretty non-committal.
In fact it might be what
happens when you start off.
If you had to choose an action in this
case, which action would you choose?
>> X.
>> Why?
>> Is that the quiz?
>> No, that's a question.
>> It's Y?
Wow, I had no idea why it would be Y.
>> Explain to me why you chose X.
Sorry.
>> I see, why I chose x?
Because well according to the algorithm,
it doesn't really care, doesn't have any
reason to believe one over the other,
but the human has reason to believe it.
I guess there's one
missing parameter maybe,
which is how much we
should believe the human.
And so,
if we believe the human not at all,
it's still not being bad to go for X.
>> But here's the thing.
We actually have that parameter.
>> That was C!
>> That was C, and in fact,
it doesn't matter what C is,
because that's all inside
this distribution.
This distribution, two-thirds,
one-sixth, one-sixth, actually already
incorporates all the information
about the uncertainty of the human.
I don't think it does.
>> Yeah, absolutely does.
The probability that X
is optimal is in fact
a function of the data that
the human has given us.
And how likely they are to be correct
in the data that they've given us.
>> But it seems like it could change
over time as we've come to believe
the algorithm more.
Then we should believe the human less.
>> It's really interesting you say that
because all the other various techniques
that have been out there in
the world actually do that.
They actually try to capture what
the human has said and what you've
learned in the world and then over time
believe the human less and less often
because whatever the real world is
telling you is got to be correct.
What's actually beautiful about
this particular mechanism that we
described in the last couple of
slides is that that parameter c,
that confidence that we have that
probability the human is correct
actually sort of captures
everything we need to know,
if we are completely certain about
the human then these numbers will
reflect that by peaking over
whatever action should be optimal.
And if we're uncertain about the human,
then these things will tend
to stay towards the uniform.